♪ (SLOW SOMBER MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
RICHARD RYAN:
I'm Richard, what's your name?
Mare.
Give it up
for Ms. Ladyhawk herself!
(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
RYAN:
Why do they call you "Ladyhawk?"
MARE SHEEHAN: I made a shot
in a basketball game,
twenty-five years ago.
They think you're a hero!
Oh, I love it, look at that.
It must've been some shot.
MARE: Most places, no.
Around here... yeah.
RYAN: What do you do, Mare?
-I'm a detective.
-A detective?
You don't have any bodies
hidden under your porch, do you?
Uh, not yet, no.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
MARE: The Easttown
Police Department received
a call reporting a dead body
in Creedham Creek.
KENNY MCMENAMIN: Get
the son of a bitch who did this.
'Cause if you don't,
I'll kill him myself.
RYAN: Tell me about your father.
SHEEHAN: He was my best friend.
He passed away
when I was 13.
He was a detective.
RYAN: At least you
still got your mother.
MARE: Oh,
we can't stand each other.
I can feel it happening again.
This expectation from people
to be something I don't think
I'm good enough to be.
CHIEF CARTER: Mare, I know
what you've been through.
And I know you're worth saving.
(CROWD CLAMORING)
The ground has just fallen
out beneath you.
Mom, you don't know what's
gonna happen, all right?
(TIRES SCREECHING)
Go back to the file, dig deep,
recommit yourself.
Doing something great
is overrated.
Put the gun down!
(SIREN WAILING)
People expect that
from you... all the time.
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
-(PANTING)
-(SIRENS WAILING)